je suis une fana de la télévision
c'est-à-dire que je suis comme un enfant
je suis depuis toujours oui je suis
fascinée par la télévision je suis
captivé je la regarde je zappe c'est
précisément parce que j'aime la
télévision que je que j'ai poussé un peu
secret de révolte contre ce contenu
parce que je me dis mais comment peut-on
faire aussi médiocre avec autant
d'argent c'est vraiment ça qui me qui me
stupéfit dans votre livre le ras-le-bol
des bébés a peur je vous souhaite une
lettre ouverte au marchand la télévision
est tombée marchands parce que je crois
que ceux qui contrôlent la télévision
sont des marchands d'images c'est-à-dire
que la loi de l'argent a tout emporté
sur son passage la loi du moindre coût
la mesure par nos images qui était un
instrument extrêmement grossier
puisqu'il suffit de regarder une
émission pour être censé la prouver et
donc le téléspectateur est piégé et sa
liberté est piégé puisqu'il appuie sur
un bouton même par curiosité et même
s'il désapprouve ce qu'il voit dans la
mesure où son regard est compté dans
l'Audi mat il est censé approuver ce
qu'il voit c'est danger